Hi, Welcome to the Quantum Labs of Michel
Devoret and Rob Schoelkopf.
My name is Florian Carle, I am the manager
of the Yale Quantum Institute and the curator
of our artist in residence program.
I developed this program to bring talented
artists to our labs for a year-long residency
to collaborate with our students and give
the general public a glimpse into quantum
physics through art.
The piece you are going to hear tonight is
“Quantum Sound: A Live Performance of Superconductive
Devices” which was developed by sound artist
Spencer Topel, during his residency in 2019
in close collaboration with quantum physicists
Luke Burkhart and Kyle Serniak.
All the sounds you are going to hear tonight
were created using these quantum computers
prototypes that are behind me, deep inside
their dilution fridge at almost absolute zero.
They have been using them as physical synthesizers
to produce the piece tonight.
Without further ado, please enjoy this performance
of “Quantum Sound”.